Angelina Jolie is marvelous as
Maleficent with part 2 mistress of evil
hitting theaters October 18th but here's
my big question can you picture her as a
superhero yes Kevin she's six children
she's already a superhero in my mother
that's a great point Angelina is in
talks to join the Marvel Universe in the
Eternals it's about two godlike groups
battling for control we assume angie is
fighting for the side of good
well either way we're in love she's bad
I'm into it too but turning into a
superhero something that my guys that
great Levi knows a thing or two about
[Music]
well thank you I've spent a lot of time
in the gym the suit also you there's
there's there's definitely stuff in
augmentation in the suit I did
everything I could to fill it with as
much real me as possible what are you I
don't know how so what makes Zachary our
new favorite superhero it's not his I
spent six days a week in the gym
physique but that does help it's more
that in spite of his rising fame
he's keeping things real it is not real
life you know this this is well it is
real life but I mean it's not normal
life it's not most people don't get to
do this and so I want to make sure that
I'm just appreciating every second that
I could get hit by a bus tomorrow you
don't know what your life's gonna do
Zachary joins the DC Comics universe as
Shazam the 14-year old boy who magically
transforms into a 30-something superhero
I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer please
now you've like gone full fledge like
I'm coming for you Hemsworth brothers
heartthrob daddy are you daddy are you
ready for like full heartthrob life in
Hollywood think about now you're in the
running for like sexiest men of the year
I mean let's not get ahead of ourselves
People magazine and the whole Shazam
game will be there tonight at their big
Hollywood premiere
[Music]